Twins have long captured the public imagination. Movie plots, ad campaigns, viral videos of twin toddlers babbling at each other in what seems like a secret language. Something about twins grabs our attention every time. But it's not only the general public that's fascinated with twins. Twins have also garnered their share of attention from psychologists and other researchers because of what they can tell us about how our genes and environment interact to make us who we are. Where is twin research today? As our understanding of human genetics has advanced in recent years, do twin studies remain vital? What about twins who are raised apart and meet later in life?
双胞胎长期以来一直吸引着公众的想象力。电影情节、广告宣传、双胞胎幼儿用看似秘密语言互相咿呀学语的病毒式视频，关于双胞胎的某些特质总是能抓住我们的注意力。但不仅是普通大众对双胞胎着迷，心理学家和其他研究人员也对双胞胎给予了相当多的关注，因为他们能告诉我们基因和环境是如何相互作用造就了今天的我们。双胞胎研究的现状如何？随着近年来我们对人类遗传学理解的深入，双胞胎研究是否仍然至关重要？那些分开抚养并在晚年相遇的双胞胎又如何呢？
What can we learn from those natural experiments? And why are so many people, scientists, and lay people alike, so fascinated with twins? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mill. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation doesn't have to stop when the podcast is over. Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names, discussing such issues as COVID-19, racism, and stigma.
我们能从这些自然实验中学到什么？为什么这么多人，无论是科学家还是普通人，都对双胞胎如此着迷？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。如果您喜欢《心理学谈话》，对话不必在播客结束时停止。注册参加美国心理学会2020年虚拟大会，只需支付一笔低廉的费用，即可无限制地访问数百个关于心理学最新进展的视频。先从我们精选的视频开始，这些视频汇集了心理学界的大咖，讨论诸如新冠疫情、种族主义和污名化等议题。
Or let your curiosity take over and use our on-demand library to explore any time. topic. Go to convention.apa.org slash podcast. That's convention.a.a.org slash podcast. Our guest today is Dr. Nancy Siegel, a professor of psychology and director of the Twin Studies Center at California State University Fullerton. She has spent her entire career studying twins, beginning with her work on the Minnesota study of twins reared apart in the 1980s and 90s. Today she continues to study identical and fraternal twins, twins reared apart, and other unusual pairings, as she calls them, even unrelated people who look like twins. She's written six books about twins and twin research and is working on a seventh.
或者让您的好奇心引领您，随时使用我们的点播库探索任何主题。请访问 convention.apa.org/podcast。网址是 convention.apa.org/podcast。我们今天的嘉宾是南希·西格尔博士，她是加州州立大学富勒顿分校的心理学教授兼双胞胎研究中心主任。她整个职业生涯都在研究双胞胎，始于20世纪80年代和90年代对明尼苏达州分开抚养双胞胎的研究。今天，她继续研究同卵和异卵双胞胎、分开抚养的双胞胎以及她所称的其他“不寻常配对”，甚至包括长得像双胞胎的非亲属关系者。她已经撰写了六本关于双胞胎和双胞胎研究的书，目前正在撰写第七本。
She is also, as it happens, a twin herself. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Siegel. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a broad question. Twin studies have a long history in psychology. Why is that and what have we learned over the years? Well, twin studies are fascinating and it's a very simple and very simple and very very elegant design. One simply compares the resemblance of identical twins who share all their
巧合的是，她自己也是一名双胞胎。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，西格尔博士。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从一个宏大的问题开始。双胞胎研究在心理学中有着悠久的历史。为什么会这样？多年来我们学到了什么？嗯，双胞胎研究非常迷人，而且它是一个非常简单、非常优雅的设计。人们只需比较同卵双胞胎（他们共享所有基因）与异卵双胞胎（平均共享一半基因）之间的相似性。
genes to the resemblance of fraternal twins who share half the genes on average. For most measured traits, we find that identical twins are more alike than fraternal twins, which is consistent with the genetic influence on that behavior. And there are many variations on what I just described, which is the classic twin method. But as you said in your introduction, we can study twins we can study twins living apart for long periods of time. And I have also been studying some very unusual pairings, which I hope we have time to get into. I'm sure we will. So you've been studying twins since the 1980s. How have the questions that you and other researchers ask changed over time as our understanding of genetics has become more sophisticated? For example,
对于大多数测量的特征，我们发现同卵双胞胎比异卵双胞胎更相似，这与基因对该行为的影响是一致的。我刚才描述的经典双胞胎方法还有许多变体。但正如您在介绍中所说，我们可以研究长期分开生活的双胞胎。我也一直在研究一些非常不寻常的配对，希望我们有时间深入探讨。我相信我们会谈到的。所以您从20世纪80年代就开始研究双胞胎了。随着我们对遗传学的理解变得更加复杂，您和其他研究人员提出的问题随着时间的推移发生了怎样的变化？例如，
a recent article in the Atlantic talked about how twin studies are advancing our understanding of epigenetics or how genes are expressed. So I'm wondering if you can explain what that means. Yes, sure. But let me just back up for a second. You wanted to talk about how questions and interests and focus has changed in twin studies over the years. So when I began in the 1980s, this was just when behavioral genetics was being admitted into this mainstream of psychology. And so investigators were interested in establishing a genetic basis for human behavior. And twin studies and adoption studies were a very effective way to go. Then things began to change and people began looking to see if they could find the actual genes that were linked to behaviors.
《大西洋月刊》最近的一篇文章谈到了双胞胎研究如何推动我们对表观遗传学或基因表达方式的理解。所以我想知道您能否解释一下这意味着什么。好的，没问题。但请允许我先退一步。您想谈谈多年来双胞胎研究中的问题、兴趣和重点是如何变化的。当我20世纪80年代开始研究时，行为遗传学才刚刚被纳入心理学的主流。因此，研究人员有兴趣为人类行为建立遗传基础。双胞胎研究和收养研究是非常有效的方法。后来情况开始发生变化，人们开始寻找与行为相关的实际基因。
And that's partly where epigenetics comes in. Now epigenetics refers to the turning on and turning off of genes. What environmental triggers, either before birth or sometime after birth, will activate a gene or perhaps silence it. And this is where identical twins who differ in fundamental ways, maybe of greatest use to us in the medical sciences, because we know that the similarity rate for identical twins are diabetes and multiple sclerosis is only 50%. Schizophrenia, maybe 40%. So if they come into the world with the same genes, why is it that one twin expresses it and the other one does not? This is information that we can all use to assist individuals who are affected in the non-twin population. And epigenetics came into play when Scott Kelly
这在一定程度上就是表观遗传学的切入点。现在，表观遗传学指的是基因的开启和关闭。出生前或出生后的某些环境触发因素会激活基因，或者使其沉默。这就是为什么在医学科学中，在基本方面存在差异的同卵双胞胎对我们最有用的原因，因为我们知道同卵双胞胎在糖尿病和多发性硬化症方面的相似率仅为50%。精神分裂症约为40%。所以，如果他们带着相同的基因来到这个世界，为什么一个双胞胎表现出这种症状而另一个却没有？这些信息是我们所有人都可以用来帮助非双胞胎群体中受影响的个体。表观遗传学在斯科特·凯利
went into space, for example, right? He's an identical twin, and his brother was on Earth. And when Scott Kelly came back, he had gone through some genetic changes. Can you explain that? Yes, he did. The flight travel that Scott Kelly took had him up at the International Space Station for almost a year while his twin brother Mark remained on Earth. And prior to the trip, they both had completed a very comprehensive set of tests, intellectual, physical, genetic, things of that sort. And they think, found that contrary to expectation, it seemed that Scott Kelly's chromosomes actually reflected greater longevity. One would expect that they should have not shown that. But most of his epigenetic changes have reverted back to what they were normally. But that is a fascinating
进入太空时发挥了作用，对吧？他是一个同卵双胞胎，他的兄弟在地球上。当斯科特·凯利回来时，他经历了一些基因变化。您能解释一下吗？是的，他确实经历了。斯科特·凯利乘坐的航班让他在国际空间站待了近一年，而他的双胞胎兄弟马克则留在地球上。在旅行之前，他们都完成了一套非常全面的测试，包括智力、身体、基因等方面的测试。他们发现，与预期相反，斯科特·凯利的染色体似乎反映出更长的寿命。人们本以为他们不应该表现出这一点。但他大部分的表观遗传变化已经恢复到正常状态。但这确实是一个迷人的
study because we will never again get two identical twins who are both astronauts and one willing to take the trip. That's amazing. And is that common with epigenetics that things revert? It's trait specific. It's trade specific. One wouldn't really know that. Yeah. Identical twins are not exact copies of each other in the sense that you've studied some identical twins who show a fair amount of physical variation, such as differences in height or hair color. What are the causes of these variations? Well, the causes of variation are many. If you talk about height and weight, it probably has to do with prenatal nutrition that might have been unequally distributed between the two twins. If identical twins share their blood systems, what we call fetal transfusion
研究，因为我们再也不会有两名同卵双胞胎都是宇航员，且其中一人愿意进行这次旅行了。太神奇了。表观遗传学中的事物恢复正常是常见的吗？这是特定于特征的。这是特定于特征的。人们真的不会知道这一点。是的。同卵双胞胎并不是彼此的精确复制品，因为您研究过一些表现出相当多身体差异的同卵双胞胎，例如身高或头发颜色的差异。这些差异的原因是什么？嗯，差异的原因有很多。如果您谈论身高和体重，这可能与两个双胞胎之间可能分配不均的产前营养有关。如果同卵双胞胎共享血液系统，也就是我们所说的胎儿输血
in the womb, that can also create differences in size and vigor, things like that sort. And if really to a severe degree, it might even lead to the demise of one of the twins. And then I mentioned the epigenetics before. If twins somehow get exposed to different environmental events, whether global or micro environmental events, this can also trigger something in one twin and on the other. Genetically speaking, too, identical twins may not be exactly alike. Sometimes there are errors in copying when cells replicate, and so there could be spontaneous mutations in one twin that the other twin does not have. So identical twins are less alike than people think they are. They're more alike than any other pair of people, but they are less alike than people think they are. And that's what makes
在子宫内，这也会造成体型和活力等方面的差异。如果程度非常严重，甚至可能导致其中一个双胞胎的死亡。然后我之前提到了表观遗传学。如果双胞胎以某种方式接触到不同的环境事件，无论是全球性的还是微环境事件，这也会在其中一个双胞胎身上触发某些东西，而在另一个身上则不会。从遗传学上讲，同卵双胞胎也可能不完全相同。有时细胞复制时会出现复制错误，因此一个双胞胎身上可能会出现另一个双胞胎所没有的自发突变。所以同卵双胞胎并不像人们想象的那么相似。他们比任何其他两个人都要相似，但他们并不像人们想象的那么相似。这就是为什么
I'm so fascinating. Now, I've seen in some interviews you've corrected people who have used the term nature versus nurture. Why do you think that term is inaccurate? It's inaccurate because it does not appreciate the interplay between nature and nurture. So we prefer to say nature dash nurture or nature via nurture or something of that sort. We try to disentangle these effects in populations. So when we say that intelligence has a 75% genetic effect or height is 95%. We're not talking about a single individual. We're talking about the variation in a population. In a single person, you cannot separate out the two
我如此着迷。现在，我在一些采访中看到您纠正了使用“先天与后天”这一术语的人。您为什么认为这个术语不准确？因为它没有认识到先天与后天之间的相互作用。所以我们更喜欢说“先天-后天”或“通过后天的先天”之类的说法。我们试图在群体中理清这些影响。所以当我们说智力有75%的遗传影响或身高有95%的遗传影响时，我们并不是在谈论一个个体。我们是在谈论群体中的变异。对于一个人来说，你无法将两者分开
because genes and environments are inextricably intertwined. You're a fraternal twin yourself. How has that experience as a twin influenced your research? Well, being a fraternal twin, I was always fascinated with being a twin, And although I never got the adulation that identical twins get when people meet them. But I knew from a very early age that there had to be something fundamentally different about us because we shared so many experiences in common and yet we were so different in appearance and our interest,
因为基因和环境是密不可分的。您自己也是一名异卵双胞胎。作为双胞胎的经历如何影响了您的研究？嗯，作为一名异卵双胞胎，我一直对成为双胞胎很着迷。虽然我从未得到过同卵双胞胎在人们见面时所受到的那种赞美。但我很早就知道，我们之间一定存在着根本性的不同，因为我们分享了如此多的共同经历，但我们在外表、兴趣、
and tastes and things of that sort. So I would say that it certainly propelled me into the field. How it's influenced me? Not really, because I let the data drive that. And I've been surprised sometimes by certain things and certain things I've expected have come true. but you have to keep an open mind. But I will say that being a twin has been a great advantage because in soliciting subjects for my projects,
品味等方面却如此不同。所以我认为这确实推动我进入了这个领域。它如何影响了我？其实并没有，因为我让数据来驱动研究。有时我对某些事情感到惊讶，而某些我预料到的事情也确实发生了。但你必须保持开放的心态。但我会说，作为一名双胞胎是一个巨大的优势，因为在为我的项目招募受试者时，
the minute they discover that I'm a twin, it creates this bond that you just understand what's going on, that we share something fundamentally important. And that's been a real advantage. There are a lot of myths and legends out there about twins that they've got some kind of a telepathic connection, that they can share secret language. And I know one of your books is called twin misconceptions,
他们一发现我是双胞胎，就会产生一种纽带，让你明白发生了什么，我们分享了一些根本重要的东西。这确实是一个真正的优势。关于双胞胎有很多神话和传说，说他们有一种心灵感应，他们可以分享秘密语言。我知道您的一本书叫《双胞胎误区：
false beliefs, fables, and facts about twins. What are some of the common myths that you address? And do any of these have grains of truth? Well, the ones that I address mostly are, I mean, there's so many, there must be out 70 that I deal with in the book. But some people think that fraternal twinning skips generations. Now, is there a kernel of truth? It could do that in some families, but there's no actual rule for that.
关于双胞胎的错误信念、寓言和事实》。您解决了哪些常见的误区？这些误区中有真实的成分吗？嗯，我主要解决的那些，我的意思是，有太多了，我在书中处理的大约有70个。但有些人认为异卵双胞胎会隔代遗传。现在，这其中有真实的成分吗？在某些家庭中可能会这样，但并没有实际的规则。
We know the fraternal twinning runs in families, but the actual mode of transmission has not been identified. Some people feel that identical twins should always be separated in school when they enter. And I'm really against that. I think you have to take every pair on a case-by-case basis. We don't have firm policies regarding singleton children, and I think that this treats twins unfairly. Other myths that identical twinning does not run in families. Now, we thought that for a very long time. And yet some recent research from Sweden and from Singapore looking at inbred populations has found that there are these pockets of people around the world in India, in Iran, where there are multi-generations of just identical twins. And so we think that within
我们知道异卵双胞胎在家庭中遗传，但实际的传播方式尚未确定。有些人认为同卵双胞胎入学时应该总是分开。我真的反对这一点。我认为你必须根据具体情况对待每一对。我们对单胎儿童没有严格的政策，我认为这对双胞胎是不公平的。其他误区包括同卵双胞胎不会在家庭中遗传。现在，我们很长一段时间以来都这么认为。然而，最近来自瑞典和新加坡的研究观察了近亲繁殖的群体，发现世界各地，如印度、伊朗，存在着一些人群，那里有多代同卵双胞胎。所以我们认为在
some families, there's this tendency toward zygotic splitting or splitting of the single fertilized egg. In my study, well, it wasn't for a study, but it was for my book Indivisible by two. It was kind of a, it's an interesting book. It's kind of like Oliver Sacks, the man most took his wife for a hat book, but for twins, where I bring in the human interest and the science. And one of the couples that I studied were actually a set of identical male twins married to a set of identical female twins. They live very close by. And one of the couples had identical twins. And so that's twins having twins. And in my book, Twin Mithconceptions, I have a photograph of identical twin women, each of whom had a pair of identical twins. So it seems that there is some
一些家庭中，存在着合子分裂或单个受精卵分裂的倾向。在我的研究中，嗯，这不是为了研究，而是为了我的书《不可分割的二分之一》。这是一本很有趣的书。它有点像奥利弗·萨克斯的《错把妻子当帽子的人》，但它是关于双胞胎的，我把人文关怀和科学结合在一起。我研究的一对夫妇实际上是一对同卵男性双胞胎与一对同卵女性双胞胎结婚。他们住得很近。其中一对夫妇生了同卵双胞胎。所以这就是双胞胎生双胞胎。在我的书《双胞胎误区》中，我有一张同卵双胞胎女性的照片，她们每个人都生了一对同卵双胞胎。所以似乎在
factor in some families that gives you this genetic tendency toward that kind of twin. And that creates some kind of a weird relationship, right? Because the twins are, they're genetically the same. I mean, so is your uncle? You're also. Well, yes. Maybe you can explain this because I'm not doing a good job. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What happens is that if you have identical twins who marry identical twins, the offspring are legal first cousins, but they're also genetic full siblings. because every parent is genetically interchangeable. That's somewhat rare, but a much more common scenario is identical twins who just marry unrelated people. And their children would be genetic half-siblings, in addition to being cousins.
一些家庭中存在某种因素，使你具有这种遗传倾向。这创造了一种奇怪的关系，对吧？因为双胞胎在基因上是相同的。我的意思是，你的叔叔也是。你也是。嗯，是的。也许您可以解释一下，因为我解释得不好。是的。是的。是的。发生的情况是，如果你有同卵双胞胎与同卵双胞胎结婚，后代在法律上是第一代堂表亲，但他们在基因上是全亲兄弟姐妹。因为每个父母在基因上都是可以互换的。这有点罕见，但更常见的情况是同卵双胞胎与非亲属结婚。他们的孩子除了是堂表亲外，在基因上还是半亲兄弟姐妹。
But I will tell you one story that I have also in one of my books, I think it was an entwined lies, my first one. I have a set of identical twins who married identical twins, and they had children on the same day, which makes them genetically equivalent to fraternal twins. But see, they're enormously informative from the point of view of research because you've got people who are, you know, you can look at the relation between, say, a twin aunt and a twin mother towards children. And they share the same genes, but one is raised with one and one is not raised with the other. So you can look at all sorts of stuff.
但我会告诉您一个故事，我也在我的书里写过，我想是我的第一本书《纠缠的谎言》。我有一对同卵双胞胎与同卵双胞胎结婚，他们在同一天生了孩子，这使他们在基因上等同于异卵双胞胎。但你看，从研究的角度来看，他们非常有参考价值，因为你可以观察，比如说，双胞胎阿姨和双胞胎母亲对孩子之间的关系。他们共享相同的基因，但一个与一个一起抚养，另一个没有与另一个一起抚养。所以你可以观察各种各样的事情。
Wow, that's wild. I can't imagine doing that genealogy. Yeah. So you address the question about twins, whether they should be in the same class, during their education, right? That's something that you've looked at. I'm wondering, when I grew up, there were twins in my school and parents always dressed their kids the same. Is there anything potentially damaging to children who don't get their identity, their own identity because they're always dressed like their twin?
哇，那太疯狂了。我无法想象做那样的家谱。是的。所以您解决了关于双胞胎在教育期间是否应该在同一个班级的问题，对吧？那是您研究过的事情。我想知道，当我长大时，我的学校里有双胞胎，父母总是给他们的孩子穿一样的衣服。对于那些因为总是穿得像双胞胎而没有获得自己身份的孩子来说，这有什么潜在的伤害吗？
Yeah, well, I think that can be a problem. And so I always encourage parents to dress the kids somewhat differently, maybe in the same outfits with contrast and colors, to have a name badge, cut the hair a bit differently, so that people will call them by their name and not by twin or hey you. I think, though, that twins should be allowed to enjoy their similarities at times, if they want to dress up alike, an occasion, nothing wrong with that. But you don't want them to rely on that to get attention from other people. The twin birth rate has more than doubled from 1980 to 2007, although it declined a little bit since then. What's caused the shifts in the rate of twinning and have you seen any corresponding interest in your work as a result of that over the years?
是的，我认为这可能是一个问题。所以我总是鼓励父母给孩子穿得稍微不同一点，也许是同样的衣服但颜色对比鲜明，戴上名牌，把头发剪得稍微不同一点，这样人们就会叫他们的名字而不是叫“双胞胎”或“嘿，你”。不过，我认为应该允许双胞胎在他们想的时候享受他们的相似之处，如果他们想在某个场合穿得一样，这没什么错。但你不希望他们依赖这一点来获得他人的关注。双胞胎出生率从1980年到2007年翻了一番多，尽管此后有所下降。是什么导致了双胞胎出生率的变化？多年来，您是否因此看到对您的工作有相应的兴趣？
Well, yeah. So in 1980, the twinning rate was about 1 in 60 babies. And later on, 20 years later, 30 years later, it was one in 33. And the reason that's gone up so much is because women are delaying the childbearing years, which creates a greater tendency for fraternal twinning. After all, for older mothers, you know, mistakes happen. And we are optimally. designed to release one egg at a time. So two eggs at a time is kind of this mistake, although kind of a pleasant mistake, but it's still something's not supposed to happen. So that's one reason. Another is that we're better able to manage twin pregnancies now so we can detect them and manage them better. And then within vitro fertilization, if women delay childbearing for too many years
嗯，是的。所以1980年，双胞胎出生率大约是60分之一。后来，20年后，30年后，是33分之一。之所以上升这么多，是因为女性推迟了生育年龄，这增加了异卵双胞胎的倾向。毕竟，对于高龄产妇，你知道，错误会发生。我们被优化设计为一次释放一个卵子。所以一次两个卵子有点像这种错误，虽然是一种令人愉快的错误，但它仍然是不应该发生的事情。所以这是一个原因。另一个原因是，我们现在能更好地管理双胞胎妊娠，所以我们可以检测并更好地管理它们。然后是体外受精，如果女性推迟生育太多年
and they're unable to conceive, then they sometimes go the root of in vitro fertilization where eggs and sperm are united outside the womb and then later implanted. And that also has increased not just the fraternal twinning rate, but also the identical twinning rate, although not as dramatically. Now, the great rise in twinning, of course, has focused attention on twins so much. We see them in literature. We see them in the news, TV commercials all the time. People are fascinated with it.
并且无法受孕，那么她们有时会选择体外受精的途径，即卵子和精子在子宫外结合，然后植入。这也增加了不仅是异卵双胞胎的出生率，也增加了同卵双胞胎的出生率，尽管没有那么剧烈。现在，双胞胎出生率的大幅上升当然使人们非常关注双胞胎。我们在文学作品、新闻、电视广告中一直看到他们。人们对此非常着迷。
And I think that leads to another interesting idea. Why? Why are people fascinated? So I began asking people and they'd say, well, they just are. They're fascinating. But I could not get an answer. So I've thought a lot about it. And I think it's because we all are raised to appreciate individual differences in appearance and in behavior.
我认为这引出了另一个有趣的想法。为什么？为什么人们如此着迷？所以我开始问人们，他们会说，嗯，他们就是这样。他们很迷人。但我无法得到答案。所以我思考了很多。我认为这是因为我们从小就被教育要欣赏外表和行为上的个体差异。
So when we encounter two people who look and act so much alike, it challenges our beliefs and how the world works. And some people find it, well, everyone finds it intriguing. Some people find it a little upsetting to see that much closeness. But I think that's the clue. And with twins raised apart, you know, we have such a strong reverence for family. The idea of these two very close people being raised apart just does not sit well. And when we hear about the reunions, they're just so heartwarming. I have a whole series of tapes of twins meeting for the first time, and I've seen it so many times.
所以当我们遇到两个长相和行为如此相似的人时，它挑战了我们的信仰和世界运作的方式。有些人觉得，嗯，每个人都觉得这很吸引人。有些人觉得看到如此亲密的关系有点不安。但我认为这就是线索。对于分开抚养的双胞胎，你知道，我们对家庭有着如此强烈的敬畏。这两个非常亲密的人被分开抚养的想法让人难以接受。当我们听到重逢的消息时，它们是如此感人。我有一整套双胞胎第一次见面的录像带，我已经看过很多次了。
And every time I tear up, it's just that moment of me, that out-of-control glee is just amazing. That's got to be a lot of fun. You go through life, thinking that it's just you, and then you discover. It's you and me. There's another one like me. Yeah. Great. So let's talk a little bit about the research projects you have going on now.
每次我都会热泪盈眶，那一刻的相遇，那种无法控制的喜悦真是太神奇了。那一定很有趣。你一生都在想，那只是你，然后你发现。是你和我。还有另一个像我一样的人。是的。太棒了。那么让我们谈谈您现在正在进行的研究项目。
You're continuing to study twins reared apart, right? I am. I have a study ongoing that looks at young Chinese twins who've been separated at birth indirectly through the one-child policy. And I get them. It's the only prospective study in the world. Most reared-to-part twins studies have found twins as adults. and had to reconstruct their childhood events.
您还在继续研究分开抚养的双胞胎，对吧？是的。我正在进行一项研究，观察因独生子女政策而间接在出生时分离的年轻中国双胞胎。我找到了他们。这是世界上唯一的前瞻性研究。大多数分开抚养的双胞胎研究都是在双胞胎成年后才找到他们，
But I'm getting the twins over time. Every pair has now had about two assessments, although I'm still completing the second one for some of the pairs. And so the twins live with different families in the U.S., sometimes in Canada or other places around the world. And so I'm able to get the twins tested in their local areas and parents fill out questionnaires. Now the kids are growing up so I can do a little more with them.
并不得不重建他们的童年事件。但我是在随着时间的推移接触这些双胞胎。每一对现在都已经进行了大约两次评估，尽管我仍在为其中一些对完成第二次评估。所以双胞胎与美国、有时是加拿大或世界其他地方的不同家庭住在一起。所以我能够让双胞胎在当地接受测试，父母填写问卷。现在孩子们正在长大，所以我可以对他们做更多的事情。
And I've studied 23 pairs of them so far, 15 identicals and eight fraternals. And I just hope I can continue because grant money is scarce. But I would just love to find some more. I really would. Now, I also do case studies on adult twins who find each other. And I've got one right now. These twins from South Korea just met each other.
到目前为止，我已经研究了23对，15对同卵，8对异卵。我只是希望我能继续，因为研究经费很稀缺。但我真的很想再找到一些。我真的想。现在，我也对找到彼此的成年双胞胎进行案例研究。我现在就有一对。这些来自韩国的双胞胎刚刚见面。
Just in the last week or so, and I'm so excited. And so I have a colleague in South Korea who will test the South Korean twin, and I'm going to test the twin who lives here. And they didn't know about the other? No, they didn't know about the other until, let's see, well, the one in South Korea knew, because what happened there was that she was out with, well, the mother had twins. She obviously knew that. The twins were maybe two or three, and the grandmother took one twin out on a walk or something
就在过去一周左右，我太兴奋了。所以我有一位在韩国的同事将测试韩国的双胞胎，我将测试住在这里的双胞胎。他们不知道对方的存在吗？不，他们不知道对方的存在，直到，让我们看看，嗯，韩国的那位知道，因为发生的事情是，她和，嗯，母亲生了双胞胎。她显然知道这一点。双胞胎可能两三岁，祖母带其中一个双胞胎出去散步或什么的
and lost her in a market, never found her again. And the twin ended up back in a orphanage and was adopted. But she never knew she was a twin until she did, it's a program now for Korea and adopties so they can submit their DNA and see if it matches. And that's how she found her family. I'm also fascinated by a study you did a few years ago on doppelgangers, the people who are completely unrelated, but they look uncannily alike. Why were you interested in studying this phenomenon and what did you learn? Yeah, that's a great question. See, there was a criticism of twin research held by some that identical twins are alike in personality because people treat them a
在市场上弄丢了她，再也没有找到她。那个双胞胎最终回到了孤儿院并被收养了。但她从来不知道自己是双胞胎，直到她做了，现在有一个针对韩国被收养者的项目，这样他们可以提交DNA看看是否匹配。这就是她找到家人的方式。我也对您几年前做的一项关于“分身”的研究很着迷，那些完全没有血缘关系，但长得惊人相似的人。您为什么对研究这种现象感兴趣？您学到了什么？是的，这是一个很好的问题。你看，双胞胎研究受到了一些人的批评，认为同卵双胞胎在性格上相似是因为人们根据他们的外表对待他们。
certain way based on their looks. And that never made sense to me. It just never made sense to me. I think what happens is that people respond similarly to identical twins, but because they evoke certain reactions from these people. So the way to test that I realized was to use unrelated people who shared no genes, but shared their looks. And so I reasoned that if they were as a like as identical twins raised apart, well, then maybe I was wrong. But if they were very different, then it would mean that their genetics were so different that they, you know, they just did not, they were not going to be similar in personality. And so I worked with somebody in Canada who, a photographer, Francois Brunel, who takes photographs of these people.
这对我来说从来没有意义。这对我来说从来没有意义。我认为发生的情况是，人们对同卵双胞胎的反应相似，是因为他们从这些人身上引发了某些反应。所以我意识到测试这一点的方法是使用没有共享基因但共享外表的非亲属关系者。所以我推断，如果他们像分开抚养的同卵双胞胎一样相似，那么也许我错了。但如果他们非常不同，那么这意味着他们的基因差异如此之大，以至于他们，你知道，他们只是不会在性格上相似。所以我与加拿大的一位摄影师弗朗索瓦·布鲁内尔合作，他拍摄这些人的照片。
He's a photographer. I think he was a doppelganger himself. And so I got some of my people from him. And then a British television show gave me eight pairs. And I find them occasionally, you know, here and there, I find. them and they're just amazing. And so I published two or three papers on these cases, and I find that these doppelgangers who were raised apart, but look a leftly like, are so different than personality. And when they meet, they don't feel a certain kinship. The identical twins feel it almost instantly.
他是一位摄影师。我想他自己就是一个分身。所以我从他那里得到了一些人。然后一个英国电视节目给了我八对。我偶尔会在这里或那里找到他们。我找到他们，他们真是太神奇了。所以我发表了两三篇关于这些案例的论文，我发现这些分开抚养但长相惊人相似的分身在性格上是如此不同。当他们见面时，他们并没有感到某种亲缘关系。同卵双胞胎几乎立刻就能感觉到。
These people are sort of curious and maybe it lasts for a minute, but it doesn't last. And do they actually see the resemblance? They always get it? Sometimes and sometimes not. You know, this is another interesting thing that sometimes Sometimes if you talk to identical twins, they don't think they look alike. It's a very, very funny thing. So how do you find participants in your studies? Is the Internet making it easier? Oh, absolutely it is.
这些人有点好奇，也许持续了一分钟，但并没有持续下去。他们真的看到了相似之处吗？他们总是能看出来吗？有时是，有时不是。你知道，这是另一件有趣的事情，有时如果你和同卵双胞胎交谈，他们并不认为自己长得像。这是一件非常非常有趣的事情。那么您是如何在研究中找到参与者的？互联网让它变得更容易了吗？哦，绝对是。
And, you know, I really have never solicited people. People come to me. I feel like Sir Francis Galton back in the 1870s, when people would say, I want to be in your studies. I mean, I'm just getting people all the time. It's just amazing. I'm lucky that I have an international network. people send me emails and contacts all the time.
而且，你知道，我真的从来没有主动招募过人。人们来找我。我觉得自己就像1870年代的弗朗西斯·高尔顿爵士，当时人们会说，我想参加你的研究。我的意思是，我一直在接触人们。这真是太神奇了。我很幸运，我有一个国际网络。人们一直给我发电子邮件和联系方式。
I found one of my most interesting pairs, well, actually the situation in Colombia, South America, involving two sets of identical male twins who'd been accidentally switched at birth. So it was an exchange of one twin from each pair. And they grew up in very different environments. And when I learned about this through a colleague, I went right down to Bogota to study them. And it was a book came out of that called Accidental Brothers, published in 2018. But let me get back a minute to the studies of twins raised apart. I think it's also important to recognize that twin studies have had a wonderful history,
我找到了我最有趣的一对，嗯，实际上是南美洲哥伦比亚的情况，涉及两对在出生时被意外调换的同卵男性双胞胎。所以这是每对中一个双胞胎的交换。他们在非常不同的环境中长大。当我通过一位同事了解到这一点时，我立刻去了波哥大研究他们。由此产生了一本书，名为《意外的兄弟》，于2018年出版。但让我回到分开抚养的双胞胎研究一分钟。我认为认识到双胞胎研究有着辉煌的历史也很重要，
but there have been a couple of blemishes along the way. And the book you mentioned earlier that I'm writing right now, my seventh, it's actually all written in the hands of the editor, so I'm a free person. But that one is going to be called deliberately divided inside the controversial study of twins triplets adopted apart. They'll be out in the spring of 2021. And I think that most of your viewers have probably seen or at least heard about the documentary film Three Identical Strangers that talked about identical triplets who were separated and in a secret study. So I went back and I researched that study, the history, the origins, the implications, all the people and the legal and ethical
但一路上也有几个污点。您刚才提到的我正在写的那本书，我的第七本，其实已经全部交给了编辑，所以我是一个自由人了。但那本书将被称为《蓄意分裂：关于被分开收养的双胞胎和三胞胎的争议性研究》。它将于2021年春天出版。我想你们大多数观众可能已经看过或至少听说过纪录片《三个一模一样的陌生人》，它谈到了被分开并在一个秘密研究中的同卵三胞胎。所以我回去研究了那个研究，历史、起源、影响，所有的人以及法律和伦理
implications. And so it's a pretty big book, but it had to be written. It had to preserve all of that. and it was a tribute to the twins who were separated at birth, who were separated because a researcher or a psychiatrist felt it was better for them. I mean, it just, there was no literature to support that whatsoever. And yeah, tell us a little bit more about this psychiatrist. His name was Peter Newbauer, right? No, no, no. Well, there were two psychiatrists.
影响。所以这是一本相当大的书，但它必须被写出来。它必须保留所有这些。这是对出生时被分开的双胞胎的致敬，他们被分开是因为一位研究人员或精神科医生认为这对他们更好。我的意思是，这只是，没有任何文献支持这一点。是的，请多告诉我们一点关于这位精神科医生的信息。他的名字是彼得·纽鲍尔，对吧？不，不，不。嗯，有两位精神科医生。
Oh, oh. Yeah. Dr. Viola Bernard was the, she was the psychiatrist that had been hired by the Louise Weywey agency and just to give advice on adoptions and things. And she felt that identical twins or even any twins should be raised at parts they'd develop their own identities and parents would not be overburdened. But there was no literature to support that. Absolutely none. But that went on nevertheless. And then this other psychiatrist, Peter Newbauer, discovered this and he decided to study the twins. It was a collaboration. And it's really hard to know which came first,
哦，哦。是的。维奥拉·伯纳德博士是精神科医生，她被路易斯·韦韦机构聘请，只是为了就收养和类似的事情提供建议。她认为同卵双胞胎或任何双胞胎都应该分开抚养，这样他们才能发展出自己的身份，父母也不会负担过重。但没有任何文献支持这一点。绝对没有。但尽管如此，这种情况还是发生了。然后另一位精神科医生彼得·纽鲍尔发现了这一点，他决定研究这些双胞胎。这是一次合作。很难知道哪个先发生，
the study, the theory. I mean, it's difficult to know exactly. And I talk all about that in the book. And so the twins were studied from the time of birth until 12 years. And of course, the data are locked up at Yale and not to be sealed until 2065. Yeah. That's another issue I deal with. And some of Dr. Bernard's materials at Columbia have been sealed too. But there's enough available there that I was able to really get a lot of material. I look forward to seeing that. So what are the remaining unanswered questions in the field? What do we still don't know?
研究还是理论。我的意思是，很难确切知道。我在书中谈到了所有这些。所以这些双胞胎从出生到12岁一直被研究。当然，数据被锁在耶鲁大学，直到2065年才会被解封。是的。这是我处理的另一个问题。伯纳德博士在哥伦比亚的一些材料也被封存了。但那里有足够的可用材料，我确实能够获得很多材料。我期待看到那本书。那么该领域还有哪些未解决的问题？我们还有什么不知道的？
I'm sure there are many, many, but maybe you can give us a few. Well, you know, one very vexing question that's still never been answered satisfactorily is why does the fertilized egg divide? What causes a divide? There are theories about it, but we really do not know. We really do not know. And it used to be thought that the timing of the split from conception until day 14 had to do with the number of placenta and the number of fuel membranes. But even that is in dispute.
我相信有很多很多，但也许您可以给我们几个。嗯，你知道，一个仍然从未得到令人满意回答的非常棘手的问题是，为什么受精卵会分裂？是什么导致它分裂？有关于它的理论，但我们真的不知道。我们真的不知道。过去人们认为从受孕到第14天的分裂时间与胎盘数量和胎膜数量有关。但即使这一点也存在争议。
So it's really, really quite fascinating. And anything else that's on the horizon that you want to tell our listeners about any other work that's percolating? I think we're still going to continue with looking at how epigenetics is going to shape our understanding of human behavior and disease, that's certainly going to take off. But I think that it's always so important to stay very close to twins just to get a sense of what they're like, because just being with them gives you so many great hypotheses about how things could happen. In Minnesota, for example, we used to see that identical twins had a lot of quirks in common. We had a pair who used to read books from back to front, and he used to wash his hands before and after using the
所以这真的非常非常迷人。还有什么即将到来的事情您想告诉我们的听众吗？还有什么其他正在酝酿的工作？我认为我们将继续研究表观遗传学将如何塑造我们对人类行为和疾病的理解，这肯定会起飞。但我认为与双胞胎保持密切联系总是非常重要的，只是为了了解他们是什么样的，因为仅仅与他们在一起就会给你很多关于事情如何发生的伟大假设。例如，在明尼苏达州，我们过去常看到同卵双胞胎有很多共同的怪癖。我们有一对双胞胎过去常从后往前读书，他过去常在洗澡前后洗手，
bathroom, all these kinds of things. And so when you see it in one person, you figure, well, it's just a habit. But with two people who do it, who are reared apart, you figure there have to be something more. And so I think one of the projects I may attempt in the fall, I'm sorry, in the spring when I teach my graduate seminar on twin studies, is I'm going to have my students go back to the older literature and document all of these unusual behaviors in the identical twins and some other ones. And we'll just see, you know, what are they? Can they? Can they? I'd be studied systematically. How do we explain them?
所有这些事情。所以当你在一个人的身上看到它时，你会想，嗯，这只是一个习惯。但对于两个分开抚养的人来说，你会想一定有更多的东西。所以我认为我可能会在秋天尝试的项目之一，对不起，是在春天我教授关于双胞胎研究的研究生研讨会时，我打算让我的学生回到旧的文献中，记录所有这些同卵双胞胎和其他双胞胎的不寻常行为。我们拭目以待，你知道，它们是什么？它们能被系统地研究吗？我们如何解释它们？
Well, Dr. Siegel, this has been really fascinating. I think the research that you do is quite amazing. And I really appreciate your taking the time to talk to me today. It's my pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.spinkingof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
嗯，西格尔博士，这真的非常迷人。我认为您所做的研究非常了不起。我非常感谢您今天抽出时间与我交谈。这是我的荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。
That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。